le préservatif féminin n'est pas en
latex
info info
effectivement il est pas en latex il est
en nitrile est ce qui fait que quand il
ya une personne car des problèmes
d'allergie qui a quelques-uns qui ont
des problèmes d'allergie au latex
on peut utiliser un préservatif féminin
il n'y a pas de risque d'allergie
sensibiliser sur le vih à travers un
quiz c'est l'initiative proposée par le
lycée emilie de breteuil de montigny le
bretonneux pour la journée mondiale de
lutte contre le sida notamment à travers
un stand d'information c'est de prévenir
les jeunes contre la maladie du sida
les élèves de seconde ont déjà eu
l'occasion d'avoir
une intervention un qui s'appelle les
après-midi du zapping
nous avons installé des distributeurs de
préservatifs à plusieurs endroits dans
l'établissement le sida touche
énormément de personnes dans le monde et
je pense que c'est un sujet qui doit
être abordée même au sein de l'éducation
nationale
accompagné du pôle jeunesse de la mairie
de montigny le bretonneux plusieurs
thématiques sont abordées transmission
du sida mode de protection et
information sur la sexualité des sujets
qui attise la curiosité des lycéens sur
les modes de transmission à ya encore
beaucoup d'idées reçues par exemple sur
le fait que les moustiques peuvent
transmettre le vih
évidemment est faux ou encore sur le
fait qu'on peut attraper le sida en
s'embrassant sur la bouche le
préservatif reste le meilleur moyen de
se protéger des études sont en cours
pour découvrir un vaccin en france entre
35000 et 50000 personnes ignoreraient
leur infection par le virus du sida